من جانبها رحبت الولايات المتحده بالخطه
الدفاعيه الجديده التي اقرتها طوكيو وقال
البيت الابيض ان الخطه الدفاعيه الجديده
لليابان تهدف لتعزيز التحالف العسكريين مع
الولايات المتحده واعلن الرئيس الامريكي
جو بيدن ان الولايات المتحده تقف الى جانب
اليابان في هذه اللحظات الحرجه مؤكدا ان
التحالف الامريكيه اليابانيه اساسي في
منطقه المحيطين الهندي
وقال مستشار الامن القومي
اتخذت خطوه جريئه وتاريخيه للدفاع عن
منطقه المحيطين الهندي من خلال اعتماد
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الجديده
واستراتيجيه الدفاع الوطني و برنامج تعزيز
الدفاع واضاف سليزا ان الاستراتيجيه
الجديده تعزز التزام رئيس الوزراء
الياباني بالسلام الدولي ومنع انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه من جهه قال وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن واشنطن تدعم قرار
اليابان قدرات جديده تعزيز الرد على
الاقليمي بما في ذلك قدرات ضربات المضاده
واضاف اوستن ان الولايات المتحده ملتزمه
بالعمل مع اليابان بدعم الاهداف المنصوص
عليها في استراتيجيات بلدين
انا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره محمد العلمي
محمد من خلال هذه المواقف للمسؤولين
الامريكيين تبدو الولايات المتحده وانها
وكانها اكبر المستفيدين من تغيير الخطه
الدفاعيه العسكريه لليابان
حسن انه يعد ذلك الانقلابا جذريا على
المواقف تاريخيه للولايات المتحده
الموروثه يعني الحرب العالميه الثانيه
حينما قيضت اليابان بانتياجها مسار سلميه
مقابل صوفير الولايات المتحده لمظله
دفاعيه همم لحمايته اليابان مياه كثيره
تحت الجسور على ما يبدو الان ستستفيد
الولايات المتحده بطريقه مباشره من خلال
همم اغتصاب تكاليف الدفاع في اسيا ومنطقتي
المحيطين الهندي والهادي وايضا رساله
لخصومها المحتملين في اسيا خاصه كوريا
الشماليه والصين واي قدرات دفاعيه اضافيه
تنضاف للموقف الامريكي الذي يعتبر الصين
اكبر تحدي استراتيجيا في العالم حتى الان
وايضا للمشاكل الدائره حتى همم كما قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي همم الى التحالف
الامريكي اليابانيه وان اليابان دائما
المواقف الامريكيه من افغانستان الى
اوكرانيا واي اضافه في ال- اا الميزانيه
العسكريه سيخفف العبء من وجهه نظر
الامريكيين عليهم وهي مطالب همم تزايدت في
السنين الاخيره واخذت لغه مباشره خلال
حكومه الرئيس السابق
حينما دعى وانتقد بشده همم حلفاء الولايات
المتحده في حلف شمال الاطلسي انهم لا
ينفقون بما فيه الكفايه على ميزانيه
الدفاع ويعتمدون على الميزانيه الامريكيه
في ذلك وبالتالي كان الترحيب بالاجماع من
كبار المسؤولين الامريكيين بالخطوه
اليابانيه شكرا جزيلا لك محمد العالمي
مراسل الجزيره من واشنطن